okay so in this video we're gonna go
over parts of the eye and the process of
vision how the eye takes in light and
that is interpreted by your brain into a
site into vision let's go ahead and get
started with the anatomy of the eye
first parts of the eye here we go so
there's a fairly typical diagram that
you'll find online showing an outline of
the major parts of the eye and we're
gonna start on the outside of the eye
and work our way in so first of all the
outer protective layer of the eye is
called the cornea and so if dust lands
or dirt or if you get something in your
eye like an eyelash the cornea will be
irritated and your eye will produce
tears which can wash away whatever the
irritant might be by the combination of
you producing tears and blinking it's
the same thing as kind of like what your
windshield wipers do on your car it
wipes away the dirt and takes away the
irritant so there's the cornea the next
part of the eye I want to mention is
called the iris this is the colorful
part of the eye this is the pretty part
of the eye it's hazel or blue or green
and the iris is simply a muscle and one
thing that all muscles can do whether
it's a muscle in your eye whether it's a
muscle in your leg muscles are designed
to stretch and contract and so you might
know that the iris is a muscle and iris
can stretch and contract depending on
how much light is visible and so in a
moment we're gonna see what happens when
the eye is exposed to light and when the
eye is in a dimly lit room we're going
to come back to that in just a moment
though so there's the part again labeled
the iris the next part I want to mention
is in the middle of the iris there's a
hole the hole in the middle of the iris
is called the pupil as the iris
stretches and contracts because their
iris is a muscle this hole gets bigger
or smaller so the hole will shrink in
bright light
and the hole will be larger and open in
dim light here's a couple pictures of
what I'm referring to in this picture
you can see the black spot is the is the
pupil the white dot in the middle of the
pupil that's probably just the flash
going off from the camera that was used
to take this picture so in this picture
you can see how the black area in the
middle the pupil is fairly large that
because that's because this person is in
a dimly lit room and when it's very
poorly lit if there's not a lot of light
the iris is gonna stretch open the pupil
that way whatever light is in the room
can hopefully enter your eye so you can
see better well watch this in a bright
room you can see the difference the
black hole the pupil is a lot smaller I
don't think this is the same person's
eye they're just two pictures that I
found that I think show the point nicely
but you can see how how much the the
pupil has shrunk because this person is
in a bright room is probably a
flashlight in the person's face moving
on though to the next part of the eye
so there's again the iris the next part
of the I want to mention is just behind
the iris it's called the lens and as
light enters the eye the the the purpose
of the lens is to focus focus light as
it enters focus light under the back of
your ID which we'll mention more in just
a moment the back of the eye is called
the retina so let's move on and continue
backwards into the eye so there I go
I've labeled the lens now as we continue
to move back we come to a fluid-filled
sac called the vitreous you might also
hear it called the vitreous humor
it's a fluid-filled sac mostly filled
with water and the vitreous is clear and
it has to be clear because again light
has to pass through it if the vitreous
we're all cloudy your vision would be
all cloudy and one of the purposes of
the Vichy vitreous is it it's because
it's filled with this liquid it has
pressure to it and it pushes against the
lens and it helps hold the lens in place
it's not the only thing holding the lens
in place but it helps
so because the vitreous is a
fluid-filled sac again it adds some of
the pressure of the eye let's keep
moving to the back of the eye
so there i've labeled the vitreous as we
keep going back we come to the retina
and the retina contains cells that are
known as rods and cones the reason
they're called rods and cones because
that's their shape there are cells that
are shaped like rods they detect light
and dark and there are cells that are
shaped like cones they detect colors and
so we have a combination of rod cells
and cone cells to detect light darkened
colors and when light strikes the retina
it will produce the retina the cells of
the retina the rods and cones
photoreceptors they will create what's
called an electrical impulse that
electrical impulse is an electrical
signal that will eventually go to the
brain and the brain will turn turn that
into an image
so I've just labeled the retina there
and the last part I want to mention at
the back of the eye in this picture is
called the optic nerve so when the
retina makes an impulse their impulse
will go up the optic nerve and the
impulse goes up the optic nerve and
directly into the brain the brain is
receiving all kinds of electrical
impulses it's receiving the brain is
receiving impulses from your ears
turning that into sound your brain is
receiving impulses from your nose
turning that into smell your brain is
receiving impulses from your eyes
turning that into vision your brain is
receiving impulses from your skin
turning that into our sense of touch and
your brain is receiving impulses from
your tongue turning that into our sense
of taste so your brain has to make sense
of the electrical impulses but your
optic nerves job is to send that
information to the brain
and so there's the optic nerve and all
the parts go ahead and pause the video
if you want to study these parts now I
want to quickly go over the process of
vision the pathway that light travels in
the animation you see number one light a
yellow beam of light is entering passing
through the cornea passing through the
pupil which is open right now and what
happens next is the lens we mentioned
earlier the lens will focus light onto
the back of the eye called the retina
the retina will then create an impulse
an electrical signal that's what that
flashing spiked shaped object is in the
animation the flashing object that's the
impulse and then the last step is that
impulse step number four that impulse
travels up the optic nerve and into your
brain and your brain will determine what
it is that you're seeing that's an
overall view or overall process of
vision
check out this wonderful wonderful video
on a cow eye dissection so if you just
click on the box it'll take you to
another YouTube video of a cow eye
dissection don't forget to come back
here though and watch the rest of this
video here's something kind of fun this
is called the Stroop effect and it's
just kind of a fun silly way to kind of
mess with your brain so the directions
say when I remove that blue box I want
you to from top to bottom there's gonna
be about six or seven words from top to
bottom read the word here we go on the
count of three read the word from top
the root words from top to bottom here
we go three two one okay that should
have been pretty easy because the color
of the of the text is the exact same
color as the actual word watch this try
this one this is a little fun
so same directions when I remove the box
from top to bottom read the words as
quickly as possible
read the word here we here we go read
the words three two one
that was probably a little harder
because the color of the text was
different than the actual word that your
brain kind of takes a moment to try to
process what it is that you're seeing
you may have seen the word green but it
was typed in red text and so you may
have said gred combination of green and
red and and then all the way down the
same thing so here we go we're kind of
at the end of this video this is kind of
a quiz to see how well you remember go
ahead and pause the video two-part
question here pause the video try to
answer number one try to answer number
two I'm gonna go over the answer in
three two one
so name the part of the eye that
stretches and then identify it I hope
you chose e the IR s the iris is the
answer to number one letter e the answer
to number two here's another one same
thing pause the video I'm gonna go over
the answer in three two one
so name the part of the eye that
contains rod and cone cells and then
identify it I hope you chose the retina
retina as the answer to number one
letter F the answer to number two here's
another one pause the video and try to
answer number one and two I'm gonna go
over the answers in three two one so
name the part of the eye that focuses
light and then identify it I hope for
number one you said the lens and you
identified it as letter B B as in boy
here's another one
again pause the video I'm gonna go over
the answer in three two one
so name the part of the eye that name
the part that protects the eye and then
identify it I hope you chose for number
one the cornea which you identify it as
letter C so here's the final question go
ahead and pause the video and try to
identify all of these parts ABCDE F and
G pause the video try to identify all
the parts I'm gonna go over the answer
in three two one
so for Part A I hope you called it the
vitreous or the vitreous gel or the
vitreous humour for Part B hope you
called that the lens for Part C hope you
called that the protective cornea for
Part D I hope you called that the pupil
for Part II I hope you chose the
colorful pretty part of the eye called
the iris for Part F the rods and cones
at the back of your I hope you called
that the retina and for part G that's
the nerve that leads into the brain
that's called the optic nerve so that's
it that's really the end of this video
here thank you for watching and I hope
you found this very helpful